[Musica]
un amore quello per l'arte che dura da
più di 40 anni nella sua vita ma quando
è iniziata effettivamente questa
passione che cosa vuol dire cercando
appunto di spiegare al pubblico essere
un gallerista buonasera non è nata da 40
anni è nata con me ce l'abbiamo dentro
poi la vita ci porta a fare magari delle
cose che vorremmo fare io sono una
persona fortunata perché vengo da una
città di provincia o venduto libri porta
a porta o penso veramente tante porta in
faccia
poi la vita mi ha portato a lavorare con
una casa editrice che con la quale sono
anche diventato dirigente e questa casa
editrice a un certo punto ha fatto una
joint ventures con una casa d'aste che
si chiamava che si chiamava che si
chiama ancora finarte ma all'epoca si
chiamava rizzoli finanze e mi ha dato la
possibilità ad introdurmi nel mondo
dell'arte cose che io desideravo però
per prima cosa vorrei chiarire un
concetto guai a fare una qualsiasi
professione per interesse economico
il massimo di noi lo diamo nel momento
in cui lo facciamo perché lo desideriamo
fare perché cerchiamo di realizzare i
propri sogni
questa è la cosa più importante io oggi
qualcuno che potrebbe dire sì è facile
per te perché ormai sei un gallerista
affermato eccetera eccetera ma io anche
nei primo orti non ho mai creato non ha
mai anteposto l'interesse economico è
quello che era la mia soddisfazione
personale che era quella di lavorare nel
mondo dell'arte poi la vita mi ha
portato a fare un lavoro anche sui
generis sul mondo dell'arte perché noi
guardiamo il gallerista molto spesso che
che compra e vende baratta fa di tutto
io invece ho impostato la mia attività
facendo il mercante
il mercante di artisti la vi è poi la
vita è fatta di incontri ho incominciato
con artisti meno importanti e poi nel
tempo ho avuto la possibilità di
conoscere un grandissimo artista che è
così si vede che è zoran music che un
giorno mi disse lei stefano mi dava del
lei
io altrettanto mi disse lei stefano ha
tutte le carte in regola per diventare
un grande gallerista internazionale però
mi deve ascoltare perché io ripresenterò
tutti i più grandi direttori di musei vi
presenterò tutti i più grandi mercanti
del mondo tant'è vero che io ho avuto
una partnership importante con uno dei
più grandi galleristi del mondo che ian
cusick purtroppo non c'è più che era il
procuratore della marina fi cassa il
proprio a cortina ho fatto una mostra di
picasso con 42 opere nel 1992 da quando
ha aperto la sua prima galleria la mia
prima galleria l'ho aperta nel 79 però
iniziato nel 76 e ho iniziato chiama
chiana io ho venduto o venduto allora
nel 79 nel 76 avevo già un figlio di un
anno e
i quadri si vendevano piuttosto maluccio
aveva un appartamento a jesolo
miniappartamento io stavo in affitto con
moglie figli e ho venduto l'appartamento
per comprarmi quadri come l'ha presa la
sua famiglia
no ma non ha fermato è chiaro però io
avevo qualcuno che dietro di me mi
diceva vai avanti e ho trovato degli
amici che mi hanno sostenuto e poi non
si sono sicuramente pentiti perché dio
contraccambiati facendo rifare delle
grandi collezioni e quindi ho continuato
la mia attività poi le case me ne sono
comprate del fondo qual è la relazione
tra arte e amore
qual è stata nella sua senza amore non
c'è arte senza arte non c'è amore
cosa vuol dire che l'arte scaturisce
dalle sensazioni che siano sensazioni di
tristezza di gioia di qualsiasi altra
cosa se un artista non mette amore e che
non esprime amore
l'arte antica è piena di quadri che
riproducono
l'amore le scene ludiche e così via
se vogliamo e quindi l'arte scaturisce
dal sentimento di un artista
l'artista molto spesso è una persona
molto sensibile molto molto delicata a
volte dedica troppo all'arte e meno alla
persona perché l'artista è sempre una
persona fragile se vogliamo perché da
tutte le sue energie nel mondo dell'arte
e in quello che vuole realizzare e
quindi tutto scaturisce dall'amore
d'altra parte i rapporti interpersonali
e la società dovrebbe darci una guida
sull'amore nocco purtroppo negli ultimi
eventi non non è proprio così vediamo
che c'è più odio che amore allora visto
che noi ovviamente abbiamo come
sottotitolo il futuro cosa farà domani
io a questo punto una serie di slide e
per capire insieme a lei da che parte
sta andando l'arte di domani
intelligenza artificiale robot sempre
più money machine learning parole che si
sentono ovviamente sempre più si leggono
e si sentono sempre di più come farà
l'arte del futuro la nostra professione
è diventata molto difficile perché le
fortune vero e proprio le facevano gli
antiquari quando non c'è la
comunicazione si potevano inventare di
tutto oggi questo non è assolutamente
più possibile ma c'è anche un'altra cosa
da dire che oggi abbiamo visto una moria
io dei dati che la moria di gallerie di
galleristi e o dei dati dati proprio
dalla rivista arte che si parla di circa
il 60 per cento delle gallerie in italia
hanno chiuso perché un po perché non
hanno saputo
a fare un progetto futuro ma molto
spesso anche perché le gallerie venivano
offerte da qualche signora che non
sapeva che fare il marito magari per
togliersi dal ritorno di faceva fare
dalla gallerista la professione
gallerista è una professione molto seria
come può essere il medico come può
essere l'avvocato con può essere
qualsiasi professionista o imprenditore
perché per fare gallerista non basta
amare l'arte
bisogna fare una programmazione bisogna
avere dei progetti
io sono stato e sono ancora tutt'ora
totora il il gallerista di riferimento
in campo mondiale di artisti
importantissimi come mito rai botero
robert indiana la razza manolo valdes
cioè tutti artisti di caratura
internazionale
questo che cosa vuol dire che il mio
mercato oggi sapendo quello che poteva
succedere io vengo dal marketing vengo
dalla rizzoli
vedendo il futuro mi sono reso conto che
se non allargato il campo di azione
della della mia attività
purtroppo l'economia italiana per
esempio ha dato dei segni
riflessione sarei stato uno dei tanti
che avrebbe chiuso quindi oggi il mio
mercato è più l'ottanta per cento fuori
che in italia detto questo vorrei
parlare di queste realtà
ecco allora le realtà nuova nel mondo
dell'arte che proiettano verso il futuro
ad esempio ne abbiamo una che anzi è una
piattaforma digitale proprio per
accedere ai contenuti arti farsi una
manna dal cielo perché è una manna dal
cielo sia per i galleristi che per i
collezionisti perché io se qualcuno è un
collezionista spero che lo siate tutti
avete la possibilità di verificare tutti
i prezzi su internet
noi lavoriamo ormai in trasparenza
totale e anzi è anche una piattaforma
che ci permette di essere contattati ciò
che vuol dire che io ieri potevo far
vedere le mie cose in galleria
oggi se io le metto su arsi pagando un
abbonamento le vede tutto il mondo e
mediamente riceviamo una due tre
richieste al giorno anche di più a volte
di opere che noi mettiamo sul sito e le
possiamo vendere in singapore in america
in russia in cina da tutte le parti
molto spesso io confesso che una
stragrande maggioranza dei miei
collezionisti non li conosco quindi
diciamo che questo cambia completamente
la modalità di accesso all'art non c'è
questo che esempi come google arsen
capture che è un'altra piattaforma di
google che mette a disposizione
dell'utente alcune visite virtuali o
anche addirittura mostrare un quadro che
non vedrebbe mai così da vicino come gli
viene permesso attraverso la piattaforma
di cui ci sarebbe da parlare molto
allora per quanto concerne google è un
servizio straordinario avvicinato i
giovani all'arte più che mai avvicinato
anche i non giovani perché possono
vedere i musei possono vedere mostre
possono essere spiegati e c'è una
maggiore sensibilizzazione all'arte in
senso assoluto quindi questi sistemi
oggi che in un certo qual modo
il più alle lista viene conosciuto ma a
volte anche penalizzato perché abbiamo
on line tutti i riferimenti nel mondo
dell'economia dell'arte e questo ripeto
non ci permette più di grandi spazi di
manovra ma di essere incanalati in una
in una diciamo così normalità di mercato
questo sistema che su google che il
consiglio non deve vedere perché più si
vede arte più si ama l'arte più si legge
più si ama leggere questo fatelo voi
grandi ma anche i ragazzi ragazzi devono
essere assolutamente sensibilizzate e
questo per quanto riguarda
l'accessibilità mentre anche per quanto
riguarda la produzione dell'arte vediamo
in questo video realizzato da un artista
contemporaneo che opera una modifica su
un'opera d'arte così importante come la
notte stellata di van gogh quindi c'è un
cambiamento attraverso le nuove
tecnologie anche in questo ambito come
sistema didattico può essere divertente
non confondiamo non confondiamo l'arte
con con i giochetti cioè questo è una
cosa che a mio avviso è simpatica e
interessante e curiosa è una novità
bellissima io l'avevo vista sul
telefonino
mi piace è una bella idea cambia il
tempo però l'arte è un'altra cosa e
un'altra cosa e cosa ne pensa di quegli
artisti che utilizzano la stampa 3d una
delle tre di printing è chiaramente un
altra delle dei grandi la stampa 3d e la
stampa 3t esiste da tanti anni perché
oggi le sculture di scultori in
particolar modo del marmo non
scolpiscono food da tanto tempo ci sono
le macchine quindi dimentichiamoci
l'artista che va con lo scalpellino nei
sempre arte questa in un certo qual modo
sì perché in questo caso si paga l'idea
non si paga il manufatto l'artista il
fontana lei lo paga per il concetto non
per per come è stato fatto il quadro
perché sennò la prima cosa che gli viene
in mente se questo lo sapevo fa anch'io
però lei fare al concetto quanto vale
quest'arte vale il giusto collocamento
del mercato nel momento in cui si
compiace vuol dire che l'arte è ormai è
un business internazionale una borsa
internazionale e l'arte
abbiamo visto che oggi a differenza di
tattica altri settori nel mondo
dell'arte sono arrivati grandi capitali
e qui non devo dirlo io basta leggere i
giornali e quindi
bene viene oggi d'arte più che mai viene
guardata con attenzione dal mondo
finanziario ci sono i fondi di
investimento ci sono le banche che
investano ci sono grandi patrimoni che
investano anzi l'arte molto spesso è
privilegiata altri settori che come le
case per esempio che sono penalizzate
per mille ragioni
vorrei dire solo una cosa poi finisco so
che abbiamo sfoderato no però abbiamo
ancora del tempo perché avremo un'altra
domanda
ecco allora io allora mi faccia verso
domanda e politico quanto può valere
l'arte invece prodotta delle
intelligenze artificiali che stanno
imparando le tecniche e storia anche
dell'auto e ora iniziano a produrre
anche loro arti efficienza
l'intelligenza artificiale io ho visto
un film e l'altro giorno che ma un po
spaventato perché il robot ammazzava
quello che l'aveva fatta sicuramente una
cosa interessante
sono sicuro che ci saranno degli
sviluppi perché i cambiamenti degli
ultimi trent'anni ci insegnano a non
dire mai niente
cioè aspettare quello che succede detto
questo sono molto curioso di quello che
succederà nel mondo dell'arte il futuro
io lo seguo sono attento il mio vivo
dalla mattina alla sera in mezzo
all'arte e quindi mi aspetto di tutto
vorrei finire dicendo una cosa signori
l'artista è uno solo la sua genialità da
sua etnia i suoi sentimenti
la sua creatività nessuno lo può copiare
bene